hi i'm sal khan founder of the khan
academy and i just want to let you know
about our india talent search as you
might know khan academy we're a
not-for-profit with a mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere and to us that means
that if you are a villager someplace and
you don't have access to a formal school
then you might be able to access a
low-cost smartphone and then be able to
self-educate yourself and one day prove
what you know so you could get a job or
go into higher education but ideally
you're using khan academy in conjunction
with a classroom where the classroom can
allow students to learn and work at
their own pace give data to teachers
free up class time for more open-ended
projects or peer-to-peer learning or
socratic dialogue and so we have a call
out for the talent the teaching talent
in india
to work with us by being part of this
talent search one you'll get a chance to
practice making videos yourself and
we're looking for folks in math and
science and
initially but eventually all subjects
but it's really it's a way for us to
find talent talent that can help us
create content that will educate tens of
millions of learners throughout india so
the opportunity here is i think pretty
exciting there will be prizes but maybe
the biggest prize of all is the
opportunity to contribute and to help
your fellow citizens
if you want to participate participate
by december 12th
and now i'm going to hand it off to
anand who is our head of content in
india
i had a great math teacher when when i
grew up and i used to keep wondering
what would it be like if way more
students could learn from someone like
him
and it also got me thinking how many
other such great teachers exist who whom
i'm not able to learn from
just because they're not able to reach
me
so i know that as a teacher what's the
biggest dream it's to be able to reach
as many learners as possible
and in india it could be like tens of
millions maybe hundreds of millions of
learners who could learn directly from
us so it's been a dream to conduct like
a talent search which would bring
together
these great content creators and create
content for math and science
and maybe many more subjects so this
year we're finally able to do it and in
this talent search we're looking for
math and science to begin with for
standards six to twelve
and uh in english and hindi again to
begin with and who knows next year we
might do a much larger project than this
so send your entries and here's grant
who won last year's u.s talent search
and who's currently a fellow
to say a few words hey everyone my name
is grant sanderson i had the good
fortune of last year being one of the
united states talent search winners
and after that there was kind of a
whirlwind of experiences i ended up
being a content fellow here i've been
working on multi-variable content and a
little bit in other math areas and
probably this goes without saying but
one of the biggest benefits of being
here is the reach and i mean the global
reach knowing that the stuff that you're
going to make actually influences a lot
of students lives out there for example
in india i'm really excited that they're
doing an india talent search for india
specific content because this means
people can create math content or
whatever else much better than i ever
could or much better than anyone here
ever could just because it is localized
in that sense so i'm excited to see what
you have to make and have fun one thing
to keep in mind when you make your
submissions is we care a lot more about
the content and the substance of your
video than the production value you
should also let everyone you know
know about this this talent search i'm
sure you might know some some really
good teachers out there and try to get
your submissions in by december 12th